do you ever get asked for make goods
when you do
ads what do you mean like if i screw
they say they say you got to do another
one for free because you messed up
the the first one i don't recall anybody
ever talking to me in that tone i don't
[ __ ] stop
yeah yeah you guys you gotta do another
one
and you gotta become free because uh
no one's lucky you're still living
that's what it is yeah no
all right uber everybody
you are never going to have another
advertiser
sponsor you again you realize that right
i don't do it because of that
that's true you do it for the fans man
because it's fun
if you're dumb enough to advertise on my
podcast just with my
reading skills alone i've already
compared the uber app to like [ __ ]
drug dealers i don't give a [ __ ]
i don't give a [ __ ] i live within my
means i'm wearing tennis shorts
nantucket you're such a rapper i drive
an eight-year-old that's a rebel bill
i drive an eight-year-old tennis shores
on the island of nantucket you stopped
telling these maniacs where i am
oh sorry that's one of the rules you
never tell him that you just you leave
him like why is he wearing tennis shorts
why would he be doing that this guy's
even weirder than i thought
i have to keep listening once you go oh
he's on [ __ ] nantucket then oh now it
all makes sense
now they're not listening and uber loses
money
all right hey guys you like making great
money right here's a really cool
opportunity i
evidently had to share with you driving
with uber uber's that populist
smartphone app that connects riders with
drivers
i take uber a bunch did you know that
nia
i love them by the way oh boy oh boy
oh my god nothing i like better than
getting into a complete stranger's car
that isn't regulated by any sort of
government
[ __ ] entity hey buddy how are you
let's roll the dice again some of them
have really interesting stories as to
why they drive with uber
[ __ ] broke man
i don't make enough money at my other
job jesus christ is that interesting
they love being their own boss don't
they work for uber
they earn great money well their cars
are halfway decent they must be
investing in real estate
it's easy to start
this happened because you're here you
just need a car and a license
exactly no other background check is
there driving with uber
got off on a murder and technicality hey
welcome to uber
driving with uber is great for anyone
who needs flexibility
parents this is a really easy way to
work around your family's schedule
students you can make some extra money
between classes doesn't that sound
filthy now's the prime
time to cash in with driving with uber
you'll thank me for telling you how to
get paid every week i could be getting
into your car when you drive with uber
call to action you got a car and a
license put them both to work for you
for you and start earning serious
life-changing money today sign up to
drive with uber
visit drivewithuber.com that's drive
with uber.com drivewithuber.com
i'm just gonna catch one up you had a
advertiser called sherry's berries
and while you were reading the copy you
just you couldn't hold it together
because it was my first time reading the
copy
yeah it was just so homophobic and
homoerotic
at the same time that i just it was it
was so silly i couldn't believe it was
actual cop
and it's just so ridiculous the permit
like i've never heard anything like that
being advertised evidently they're
delicious
still still making chocolate covered
trucks
yeah and they dropped me after a while
you know what happened was i had
harris stanton was on and they was like
we have
strawberries you know drip you know
dunked in white chocolate and then they
we have
you know and dark chocolate said go
ahead and i've just jokingly said to him
he's black i said how come the white
chocolate comes before this and
we started riffing on the clan or
something and then i don't know how
i don't know then it was just people are
going to think that strawberries are
made by the clan i don't know what they
were saying
right yeah i'm still sad they left i i
loved
how i love going sherry yeah i mean
dude how many ads go viral i've been
thinking about i've never bought
sherry's berries well they told me to
take this down
really and then and then because in the
end i said you guys better buy this [ __ ]
because i'm gonna get in trouble
and then people bought it and then they
quickly were smart enough to be like
okay leave it up leave it up and then we
had this really cool thing where i felt
like
cherries beer they get me this might be
my the favorite name of anything i've
ever
advertised here uh other than one white
charlie's
uh sherry's berries
it says insert story when you've given
or received
uh the gifts well i i've been out of
town i haven't gotten
sherry's berries yet ever all right
sherry's berries since the end of the
year is all about delicious holiday food
why not send an extra special holiday
treat to friends
family business associates associates
everyone you know
i've never met a person who didn't love
sherry's berries
sent giant dipped strawberries from
sherry's berries
for only 19.99 that's over a forty
percent savings
go to barrys.com click on the microphone
and type in bur
burr for my listeners double the berries
for just ten dollars more berries are
terrific
and a sweet holiday gift they also have
delicious products such as christmas
cake pops
cheesecakes and dipped pretzels here's
the only way to get
this special 1999 sherry's berries offer
call 866 fruit
i'm sorry
what the [ __ ] am i selling
did i approve this this is [ __ ]
ridiculous
who the [ __ ] is gonna buy this [ __ ] this
is the funniest [ __ ] i've ever
seen in my [ __ ] life
christmas cake pops cheesecakes and
dipped pretzels
call 866 fruit everybody
ate some sorry 866 fruit 0-2
or even better visit berries.com
oh punch struck oh please spell out the
words oh by all means berries
b-e-r-r-i-e-s
berries click on the microphone on the
top right corner and type in burr
you got to see these enormous berries
for yourself
go i swear to god this is the copy go to
berries.com
click on the microphone and tip in burr
type in bur dip your balls and dip your
berries in that don't wait now
order order some chocolate berries for
the [ __ ] person in your life
oh [ __ ] i needed that that was wonderful
i'm sure i'll get some complaints on
that one we need a conference call
can't do it i'm in helsinki hey you
[ __ ] better buy some sherry's berries
because i'm going to get in trouble with
that [ __ ] read and i'm not changing
it because that was hilarious
um wiping tears away here
all right score big everybody
you're paying too much for tickets
between all the markups last minute
convenient charges even printed home
fees you end up paying courtside prices
for nosebleed
bleed seats sorry score big is here to
change that
guys i don't know about this company to
be honest with you i think this is just
another [ __ ] scalping site
you know i think what they're claiming
they end up doing did you know that 40
of all live event tickets go unsold that
no
that's not true that is not true
that isn't i know what happens is you
[ __ ] [ __ ] going you buy
them up and act like you got them
something happens i don't know this is
this so [ __ ] thing seems fishy to me
and did you know there's a place to get
seats at huge savings it's called score
big
score big works directly with your
favorite teams and artists to get oh
good so they get a cut
an artist to get their unsold seats at
unpublished prices that's
[ __ ] that's [ __ ] people scalp
tickets to my shows all the [ __ ] time
and fans end up yelling at me and i'm
not i don't make any money off of that
i get that all the time dude you're
funny you're not this funny and then i
look and i go jesus christ then i called
my agent what the [ __ ] are we charging
all this money for he's like we're not
doing that those are scalpers
i don't maybe scorpio maybe score biggs
on the level
i'm gonna have to do a little research
here only with score big can you name a
ticket price and be guaranteed to pay
below box office
up to 60 off now see right there they're
talking some [ __ ] there
below box office so if box office says
100 bucks
you know then you should be getting it
for 40 right
or at least under whatever the [ __ ] that
you guys they're saying up to 60
off all right here's what you do one go
to scorebig.com or download the new
score big app on your iphone and find
the events
and tickets uh the seats you want two
make an offer with scorebig's name a
ticket price feature three get an
instant answer and save up to 60
on your tickets ah maybe they're not
that bad name any fees
never any fees and shipping is always
free you can count on unbeatable prices
and great seats and when you're in great
seats you actually enjoy the game or
the show all the more next thing you yes
you stand down there taking a [ __ ]
selfie
um next time you go see any game or show
go to score big first
and see how much you can save for the
easiest way to save
on tickets download the new score big
app for your iphone
enter promo code burr at checkout and
you'll save an extra twenty dollars off
your first ticket price no iphone no
problem get twenty dollars off online
two at scorebig.com that's scorebig.com
promo code bur
score big.com promo code burr
that's it right dakota access pipeline
oh okay that's that's part of a question
sitting there reading it like what the
[ __ ] is that
i thought that was like the end of the
copy like that was some code to save
money
that's somebody's question all right
hang on a second
jesus christ
[Music]
um headspace man
all right let's be honest most of your
problems start with your mind
fear anger stress oh jesus was i not
telling the perfect
story fear anger stress anxiety
depression
sleeplessness they begin in your head
but they can wreck your life um
please include all of the following
points during your read
why did they write that
i'm gonna read everything that you wrote
all right i've said this on numerous
episodes
okay but it doesn't have to be that way
you can make a major difference in just
10 minutes a day the change comes
through guided meditation i need this
[ __ ] man
with the new headspace app man
headspace man is meditation made
simple it's guided meditations that you
listen to
whenever you want wherever you want
right on your phone
computer a tablet meditation is rooted
in thousands of years of tradition
and we're going to take that tradition
and throw it out the [ __ ] window and
let you do it as you drive down the
highway
um
you know recently i saw a yoga
instructor saying he was quitting it
because
like all of the it's been distilled down
to just getting the [ __ ] killer body
you know anyways with thousands of
scientific studies that show
its positive effects like improving
focus and relationship harmony and
decreasing anxiety and stress
join over 5 million users already
getting some headspace man for free
right now
i don't understand why i would need to
be able to do it i guess if i'm on the
road
and i'm in the quiet of my hotel room
you know as i listen to the people
[ __ ] on the other side of the wall i i'm
able to block it out
through deep breathing and focusing and
quieting my mind
becoming one with the universe hey
they're [ __ ]
maybe i'm [ __ ] too it's a threesome
now download the free headspace fan
app and begin their take 10 program for
10 days of guided meditation
at headspace dot com slash burr the
headspace take ten program is a hundred
percent free
it's a hundred percent free way to
experience the benefit of meditation
in your busy modern life learn how to
read out loud better without stumbling
over your words train your mind for a
healthier less stressed
life start with your free trial today
at headspace.com burr that's
headspace.com
burr